26 mars 2016 les visiteurs du zoo de
beauval peuvent faire du nez à nez
vitray avec des hippopotames kiwi la
femelle est arrivé il ya dix jours d'un
parc italien le mahdi peau c'est 'qui
dos il a trois ans et a passé le début
de sa vie en république tchèque
la mise en contact entre les deux
animaux s'est bien passé mais kiwi
apparaît déjà comme plus farouches
malgré ces démonstrations derrière la
vitre déjà elle a mis dix jours à entrer
dans le box pour être transféré le mâle
rend très bien
la femelle c'est plutôt nous qui l'
attendons mais on a des bons vins dits
c'est à dire qu'ils se nourrissent bien
ils vivent bien on n'a pas deux ans n'a
pas de signes de stress ou quoi que ce
soit les hippos profite bien de leur
bassin profite bien leur parc extérieur
donc pour l'instant nous c'est une bonne
action une bonne acclimatation
premier objectif atteint le deuxième
c'est la possibilité de voir des
hippopotames en vision sous marine pour
la grâce d'un mammifère amphibiens de
plus de deux tonnes pour la femelle 3
tonnes 2 pour le mal il fallait donc des
baies vitrées capable de résister à la
pression d'un bassin de mille mètres
cubes d'eau au total 44 mètres de long
dont 22 d'un seul tenant
la plus grande à ce jour en france pour
que les hippopotames voit bien les êtres
humains et vice versa il faut aussi que
l'eau soit clair avec les hippos c'est
pas du gâteau parce que l'animal évolué
dans l'eau nash dans l'eau et rejette
tous ses excréments dans l'eau si bien
que sur les sept millions
d'investissements pour concevoir la
réserve africaine 30% ont été consacrés
à la filtration cette grande salle et
donc la station d'épuration perso des
hypo la condition sinequanone pour une
vision sous marine en compagnie de
clouer kuito ou renouveau nos
installations en permanence mais surtout
les animaux bouge
inès certains arrivent certains
repartent plus de 500 animaux rentrent
et sortent chaque année de beauval donc
il ya en permanence du nouveau il n'y a
pas au juste cette année que les
hippopotames de nouveau 10 au vpn
installations nous avons nous améliorons
sans cesse part parce que nous sommes
avant tout des passionnés
car au delà de la performance visuelle
le zoo de beauval a voulu recréer un
cadre cohérent avec aux côtés des
hippopotames des potamochères des
cochons sauvages africain ainsi qu'une
immense volière avec plus de 150 oiseaux
africains pour jouer la carte de
l'immersion à fond